Selecting by tag is less than helpful.
In fact, if you think you need to use jQuery to select all of a specific tag on
a page, you might want to rethink what you're doing
because there's probably a better way to accomplish what you're trying to do.
Usually, we only want to select a handful of DOM elements for changes.
Classes offer a more specific selector that's much more
applicable to the real world.
To select all elements of a certain class name,
simply pass the class name with a dot in front as a string to the jQuery object.
For instance, if you want to select all elements of class green, you could call
the jQuery object and pass it a string of a dot followed by green.
This string that you're passing in looks a lot like a CSS selector, and
that's because it is.
In fact, any valid CSS selector is also valid in jQuery.
For this quiz, you'll be working with the sample page again.
I want you to select all elements of the class article-item, and
save them to variable articles.
Once again, you can check your work by console.logging the resulting
jQuery collection.